we don't like this where a brutal battle
is still raging for a strategic city in
the eastern part of the country
ukraine's president predicts that russia
will escalate attacks this week
americans as you know have been part of
this fight as well including two who
were captured by russian forces chris
libsay is in ukraine where he spoke to
another american who fought alongside
them chris good morning to you
good morning gail new video has emerged
of those two americans captured in
ukraine along with a new voice from an
american who fought with them and spoke
to us here in harkev
they they wound up out here
a bit by accident
they wanted to do good
in
this is
sort of the res i suppose the the
unfortunate result of that an american
on the front line insisting he remained
anonymous because he fought alongside
andy wynn and alex drewkey before they
were captured and resurfaced on russian
media speaking under duress
in newly released footage drookie says
he's been repeatedly beaten and at one
point the two were bound blindfolded and
forced on their knees drewkey said he
thought they were going to be executed
what do you know about prisoners of war
in this conflict
so we were
advised
a while back that
that
execution could be a possibility
i'm very happy that
they did not follow through with that
though their whereabouts remain
uncertain at one point in this video
drewkey's interrogator says they are in
an area held by pro-russian separatists
in that same area earlier this month two
brits and a moroccan were found guilty
of fighting alongside ukrainians and
sentenced to death
anything you would say to andy and alex
i would apologize why would you
apologize
because they sort of followed me out
here
you know we we all agreed
there was no there was no leader in the
group but
yeah i feel i definitely feel a bit
guilty
without a doubt
we should have taken
a
closer look at more humanitarian options
or training options
if we did then
they wouldn't be in the situation
they're in
now that fighter says he's in touch with
the state department which told him
they're doing everything they can he
also says the best case scenario for his
imprisoned friends is a prisoner swap
with russia nate
heartbreaking stuff chris livesay in
ukraine thank you